a stopped watch a big red symbol and
some unique monsters at just a few of
the ways HBO is letting fans of the last
of us know their show will include
plenty of familiar sights from the games
it's set in a devastated
post-apocalyptic world but the last of
us isn't all doom and gloom the game
does have its brief and Beautiful
Moments Of Hope often shared between
Joel and Ellie on their long road
together with one in particular having
major significance for fans that's the
end of the first game approaches Joel
and Ellie come across a pair of wild
giraffes who have been roaming free it's
a totally new experience for Ellie
beautifully captured in the game it
strengthens the bonds between these two
strangers it's got its ups and downs
foreign
[Music]
there was a moment near the end of the
trailer for the HBO series that shows
the two looking at something out of shot
with Joel observing Ali's reactions
rather than looking ahead it's entirely
possible this is a live-action
Recreation of the giraffe moment if it
is it will undoubtedly make viewers Die
Hard fans or not sub uncontrollably
besides will look to be stunning shot
for shot reenactments of major moments
from the game that Caesar also includes
familiar and unfamiliar characters
there's a brief but pretty intense first
look at Nick Offerman as a shotgun
toting recluse Bill who appears from
other sights on Joel after seemingly
falling into a trap regardless of how
things look these two are on reasonably
decent terms with Bill being a supply
man for Joel Bill's just paranoid and
doubtful of anyone that isn't him or his
loving partner Frank another character
played by Melanie Linsky also makes a
brief appearance linsky's name has been
absent on the cast list with the actress
herself even proclaiming it as a
surprise on Twitter might she be an
all-new character in this well-known
story more importantly just which side
of Joel and Ellie's Journey Will she end
up on
it's clear that HBO's take on the last
of us has tried to be as faithful to the
game and its characters as possible one
of the trailer's first shots lingers
upon Joel as he sits silently his
choir's contemplative mood lets the
camera Linger on his signature
wristwatch as fans of the game know the
timepiece is a gift from Joel's late
daughter Sarah she gives it to him for
his birthday as he wears it during their
fatal escape from Austin from that point
on the wash becomes a symbol of Joel's
guilds over his survival and how his
life stopped Frozen at that very moment
fans of the series will notice that the
watch on Joel's wrist is set to the
exact time when it was stopped forever
during Joel and Sarah's desperate escape
attempt
passing rage zombie parts mushroom a
clicker is what happens when an infected
person has mutated from the fungal
infection after about a year clickers
use echolocation to track their victims
hence their name
[Music]
shown near the tail end of the trailer
these monsters are absolute nightmare
fuel in the games the best tactic to
avoid an encounter with a clicker is to
stay quiet and distract them if you can
but some encounters are unavoidable and
we're likely going to see Joel and Ellie
have some very intense altercations with
these creatures
one of the first images shown in the
trailer is two people painting over a
big red logo fans of the video games
would immediately recognize this as a
firefly logo the fireflies are an
important group in both the last of us
and The Last of Us Part Two they were a
militia group that rose up against the
military occupation of numerous cities
in the United States after the outbreak
the United States government sent troops
to most of the biggest cities in the
country in an attempt to restore
government control but the fireflies
refused to give in as a result many
cities became the size of battles
between the military and the fireflies
in the HBO series The Firefly's presence
can be felt in the quarantine Zone we
see Joel roaming around not only have
they already set up in the area but
their deeds have become so Infamous that
people need to cover up any evidence of
them
at one point in the trailer Ellie is
chained up with a restraint around her
ankle Well normally this would be
considered an abusive act The Last of Us
fans though this is for a good reason in
the video game Ellie was bitten by an
infected weeks earlier and we find out
she's immune to the usually fast-acting
cordyceps infection look at this
how you got infected
that's that she could provide a cure
that the crumbling world is desperate
for but the Smugglers are better safe
than sorry when it comes to risking a
brain-eating virus obviously Ellie
doesn't stay restrained for long and her
immunity to the virus is why she needs
to get across the country but things
somehow only get worse for Ellie Joel
and Tess as they make their way to the
fireflies
well Joel's friends might be scattered
throughout the post-apocalyptic world
one person that stands beside him for a
while at least is his brother Tommy seen
for a split second looking through a
fire at his brother this take on the
character is played by Gabrielle Luna
who has appeared in as many big
franchises as Pedro Pascal who plays
Joel the former Ghost Rider from Agents
of Shield and one time Terminator is
fighting for his life just like everyone
else in HBO's upcoming show it's just a
question of how that will impact his
relationship with his on-screen big
brother in the game Tommy is seen at the
start of the virus before dipping off
the radar and forcing Joel to reunite
with him their meet-up is a Tense one
for complicated reasons so it'll be
interesting to see just how much you'll
be present in the series and how long it
will be before he and Joel team up again
foreign
[Music]